good morning believe nation today's
message is create your own path over to
you Stephen Colbert while traditional
paths may seem harder to find that also
means that you may lune learn sooner
than most generations the hard lesson
that you must always make the path for
yourself there is no secret society out
there that will tap you on the shoulder
one night and show you the way because
the true secret is your life will not be
defined by the society that we have left
you
to paraphrase robert bolt society has no
more idea of what you are than you do
because ultimately it has only your
brains to think with every generation
must define itself and so make the world
that suits itself so if you must find
your own path and we have left to no
easy path then decide now to choose the
hard path that leads to the life and the
world that you want I think too many
people are trying to live someone else's
path you're trying to follow your
parents path you're trying to be the
next Michael Jordan or the next wing
recipe or the next Steve Jobs you're
trying to be the next somebody else
where if your goal is to be the next
somebody else you're always gonna fall
short you can't out Steve Steve it's not
happening it's not gonna be possible so
you will always fall short if you are
trying to follow somebody else's path
the key is to create your own unique
path that's where you're gonna stand out
and that's where the magic is gonna
happen
you already are unique you already are
the first and only version of you that
will ever walk this planet that has
already happened but you're not the best
you yet you're the unique you you're the
first few but you're not the best you
yet and that's where you can pull from
people you can pull from jobs you can
pull from gates and you can pull from
Winfrey and you can pull from
you can pull from all these people to
make you the best version of you and
help you go off on your path and it
starts by understanding what your one
word is living your life on purpose
knowing what your values are and having
the self-awareness to create something
that is important and then by embracing
the genius of the end we're the unique
talents that you have get mashed up
together in a way that nobody else can
execute on and it often counts why I
want to do this or I want to do this or
I want to do this and you've got two or
three or four things that you don't know
which direction to take and the real
answer is to smash all of those things
together because that's the unique thing
that only you can do anybody can be a
banker anybody can be a salsa dancer
anybody can be a gamer anybody can be a
fill in the blank but when you start
combining those things together and then
combine it with your one word which is
your value system that's something that
nobody else can do is something nobody
else can touch now you're off creating
your own path and being the best version
of you and that's where your ultimate
success happiness wealth and impact will
come create your own path so the
question of the day today is I'm curious
how are you creating your own path what
are you doing to create your own path
and ignore the naysayers and not have
the temptation to just follow somebody
else has already done it what's the
unique path that you are on leave it in
the comments below I'm gonna join in the
discussion I also want to give a quick
shout out to Neil Kerr from Australia
Thank You Neil for picking up a cup of
my book really really means a lot to me
so thank you guys again for watching I
believe in you I hope you continue to
believe in yourself and whatever your
one word is I'll see you soon
this race Toki we go